je sais pas si je vais y arriver je
t'appelle élire c'est sûr qu'elle y est
tu m'appelles c'est quoi mon prénom
s'est dit d'accord cela on est prêts
longs cheveux d'accord bah oui j'arrive
oui http si vous voulez qu'on coupe le
regard sur cheval a maintenu à 9,1
c'est un pericolo c'est la tendance
alors un autre prévenu alors là alors là
la lâcheté explique te dit je te fais
comme gina on peut se parler de minutes
j'y vois un nom à temps quel truc la
bay'a gina on peut se parler de minutes
oui pourquoi pas s'ingérer dit vrai tout
et non j'ai la tête d'un mec normal et
qui sort de chez le coiffeur
je suis de paris soit vite
attention on y va je suis content en la
dotant la dot on n'a pas que ça à foot
dernière pour se faire plaisir mais
après la figurante te coucher relations
ok c'est moi parce qu'on aime bien
attention car là c'est lourd boris c'est
toi qui as fini le nutella
mais c'est encore un troisième paquet
dans sa salle contre aux affaires sur ça
la dernière allez une dernière c'est
vraiment c'est un malade en fait sa
dernière fétiche possible mais il faut
faire sensiblement la sport c'est juste
un prénom un temps la spa mais les
autres il s'agit là d' in oui il veut
aller tu veux la paix est aussi attendu
dans tout la tête après la phase aller
du temps dominique garde mobile et
perruques farnham et ça c'est un enfant
lui a donné une chaîne de télé tadjou
veut la paix la nouvelle aplanir ces
bourses on kiffe hockey de question
qu'il soit par là alors bien géraldine
oui
c'est là que des délits qui est toujours
en vie quand il veut donc merci c'est
vous êtes l'avenir